so you're running for Labour leader
you've got four nominations for NP so
far one of those is yourself it's not
looking great is it a lot clearly I wish
I wish my mom could nominate me as well
that would be fantastic wouldn't it but
I think not quite in the rules look it's
hard and I think some of the things that
I'm saying aren't necessarily things
which everyone after a devastating
defeat want to hear but the reality is
unless we transform ourselves to the
party transform how we organize and
transform the culture of our party stop
the tribalism within our party we won't
be able to win in the next five years
and I think if you understand that it's
democracy that has to be at the heart of
everything we do as a party so that we
can be the change what you want to see
in the rest of the country and that
means some quite radical changes to how
we operate it means that we need to for
example cooperate with other political
parties we have to embrace proportional
representation and radical
constitutional reform these are things
that the Labour Party will have to do if
it wants any chance of being able to
reconnect and work with other parties to
be able to win a general election in
five years time what kind of policies in
particular do you think aren't going
down so well with your policing but I
think look if you're going to talk about
radical democracy radical constitutional
democracy what does the new king so for
example the form of a House of Lords
devolution embracing portion
representation enabling a convey a
constitutional convention so that the
public can actually have a say over the
kind of state that we live in the kind
of voting system that we have it's about
letting people have real say and real
agency over their lives now if you're
gonna say that for the country you also
have to ensure that you as a party are
also walking the walk and that means
things like for example allowing local
CRPS to decide whether based on
candidates in the general election these
are things like for example whether you
want Scotland and Wales to have a say
over whether they're going to call for a
second independence referendum in
Scotland and will they support it and
these are things allowing people and
localities to have real same power you
talked a lot about party democracy and
empowering conference in particular well
one of the things that people at
conference voted for was abolishing
private schools do you think that should
be Labour Party policy yes I do
I think if you understand that private
schools are an engine of inequality and
of how they operate I understand that
lots of people out there send their
children to private school for a variety
of reasons and there are many schools of
a private square private schools in my
own constituency where I go and talk to
the students and those schools are
fantastic but I would like that standard
for every child in this country
shouldn't just be determined by the fact
that you have the money to be able to
pay for your child to have that quality
of education it should be available to
everyone and I think that division
within our society at such an early age
has consequences for the inequality that
we have not just in terms of wealth but
power as well and I think that's a very
I think was a very good policy and I
think it's one that could be
communicated perhaps in a better way but
ultimately yes I do I support it on
Friday talk about referendums democracy
on Friday
you said about the royal family you can
just put the quote in the wall why not
have a referendum in this country on the
future of the royal family we're a
democracy I'd rather see us as citizens
and subjects so would you like to see a
referendum on the future of the royal
family so what you'll see in manifesto
though we've lost today I wish which
camera this one trying to transform to
win we're one of the key things we're
talking in here is about a
constitutional convention and that would
look at things like devolution House of
Lords the the makeup of how we actually
vote portion of representation and you
know we live in the 21st century now and
I think that if you're going to allow
people a real say over the kind of
country they want to live in it may well
be one of those that constitutional
conventions that people actually say
we'd like to talk about the entirety of
the state and that could well include
the royal family what size it is what
its function is I think we've seen this
week there is a great love for the royal
family in this country but there's also
I think some concerns about how it will
go forward into the future and I think
giving people real power a real agency a
real save their lives if people wanted
to have that referendum then that would
be up to us and I think how do you think
that was would you vote for his be
scrapped I'd listen to the debate and
idle actually review I'm a Republican
I'm a Republican I believe I'm a citizen
well I think maybe moderated maybe
changed but I actually want to be a
citizen in this country not a subject I
want to have real say real power what
might I want my community to have real
state real power over its
I think it's entirely acceptable there
are people in this life there are
democracies all over the world where
they do not have a real family but that
shouldn't be for me as leader or as
Prime Minister one day to dictate what
happens that should be for the people
this country to have a say and I came to
talk about brexit clearly a big issue in
the last Oh general election now in 2019
you tweeted this in response to an
attack on the activist and columnist
Owen Jones you said welcome to brexit
Britain to be frank I've had enough of
this reactionary right-wing and race
this endeavor we need to end it now yeah
do you think brexit is a racist endeavor
I think part of the brexit campaign and
part of the undertone of brexit from
some politicians nigel farage and others
had racism at its core at its heart they
used it as a Mecca Nam to divide our
communities to divide our country and
one of the things about being do you
think brexit is a racist endeavour but
if you think about moving like there's a
potential for brexit and I think we've
seen it you know how many how many
people of color how many black people on
the day after the referendum woke up
with a sense of dread because of what
had happened ultimately our country had
chosen to listen to Boris Johnson
someone who has a track record of racist
commentary of giving credence to racism
to Nigel Farage someone who stood in
front of a poster which was a vert
lyricist this was a government that had
the Windrush scandal that had had go
home vans so I think for anyone to say
that there was not an element of racism
in the brook in the brexit project as an
endeavour you're you're basically wrong
and I think you can see that and I think
ask the millions of black people in this
country who understood what much of the
dog-whistle politics and tone was on
this issue then I think you understand
that was component now that doesn't mean
that every single person I voted for
Brecht is array.c some of my family
voted for brexit but I think that there
were drivers within that campaign which
certainly were very unsavory and which I
would call racist I spent yesterday in
Crewe and Nantwich with the former MP
Lord Smith who lost a seat at the
election she said that Breck so it was a
huge issue in that area Lee voting area
big reason why labor lost at sea do you
think comments like yours are part of
the problem no because I think unless
you're honest and truthful about what
brexit was about there are lots of
reasons take back control meant many
different things to some to people for
some people it was about taking back
control of the immigration system for
some people have about taking back
control their lives taking back control
of allowing us to spend more money on
the NHS whatever the reason was that
they believed it but my comments and I
think now the future of the Labour Party
is up and that stake I think one of the
key things for myself for many others in
the parties that we don't want to see
our party triangulate on the issue of
racism what the challenge now is for our
countries what kind of country do we
want to be do we want to be an
inward-looking
close-minded the xenophobic country or
do we want to be an outward-looking
tolerant an open country and if you know
what if people have racist views it's
the job of the Labour Party to challenge
them and explain to them that there is a
different way of going about things and
actually it's about bringing our
communities together not separating them
dividing them and my fear is in the
future that's what the Conservative
government will try to do it would try
to bed in and divide communities using
all kinds of negative english
nationalism to try and divide people
apart we don't want to see that and the
Labour Party must be a force for good in
this country and while we've got you a
campaign event in Brixton this week you
suggested that structural racism could
be part of the reason you haven't won
support from your colleagues she said
it's possible to be in the parliamentary
Labour Party and be sexist and be racist
in some ways apart these structural
issues do I think that's the only reason
that I'm on the nominations that I am no
I think it's more complex but do you
think racism is part of the reason
you've only got four nomination I guess
the question I would I would turn back
on you is why do we think there hasn't
been a woman a female leader of the
Labour Party and I would say answer the
question for that because of that is
because we have something called
structural sexism within our society we
have structural sexism and we have
structural racism do I think that if you
go to the PLP and speak to the men that
they are a vertically sexist no I don't
just they don't believe they're overtly
racist but these issues these themes run
through our society we can see it I can
see it we can see it with Megan Marco
and the way that she's been treated in
the media we know that this is a reality
the 21st century still after 400 years
of racism you can't just overturn it
overnight it's something that we're
gonna have to work on but structural
sexism structure racism exists within
our society in the PRP the Labour Party
is part of a society and it's for us to
challenge that and to make sure that we
do better I've never said that it's
because of my color that I'm not being
nominated by my parliamentary colleagues
but what I was saying was if you want to
understand why we haven't had a woman
why we haven't had a person of color as
a lead of life party then we have to
look at the entirety of the issue which
is that those structural issues do exist
now I've been told I have to wrap the
interview but I just want to ask
something really really quickly before I
do sorry and if you don't make it
through who are you gonna back for
leader I think I'll listen to what they
say I hope if I'm not in it myself I
hope that many of the candidates will
listen to what we've put forward take a
look at the manifesto transform to
change I see it we tell me what I want
to hit the so at the moment I haven't
heard very much coming from any of the
candidates so let's hear what they've
got to say